Hi, there Steve Kaufman here today to do a video in response to the wonderful video that Benny the Irish Polyglot and his
friendly Polyglots put together
to congratulate me on 10 years on YouTube. I will put a link to the video up in the description box. I've even got my
jacket and tie on here because Benny has a
bowtie in his and I feel I have to be a little formal in my response. Although
I have my golf shorts on because I'm going golfing.
Thank you very much.
I'm blown away by the video...and...I always like to take a lesson from things that happen and somehow relate them to language learning.
And so there are two things that sort of come out sort of strike me in this video. First of all is
the sheer effort that went into putting the video together. Effort, wit,
creativity,
cooperation.
And it's something that I admire in Benny,
and that is, you know, he has an attitude which is "just do it". Whether it be
just speak the language from day one or in the case of putting a video like this together, it's a lot of work.
You can think it up, that's one thing, but to actually go ahead and do it and make it happen
that's another thing. and all of the people who participated in this video
not only did they put a lot of thought and and probably several trial runs into
their participation, but these are also people like Benny who have put the effort into learning other languages many languages. And
again, it's not as some people like to say "oh, well you have a talent for languages",
it's because these people decided to "just do it". I think that's a Nike slogan or something.
I hope I don't get into trouble for using it but any
of you out there who's ever thought of learning a language it starts by
just doing it. The second point that I want to make is that
the people who are on that video, all of whom I have met except for I think Michael Campbell,
they're
representative of the polyglot community. People that I met in Montreal last year,
in Bratislava recently that I'm going to meet again in Montreal on the 25th of August.
These are the
friendliest,
supportive most
mutually encouraging group of people
I have come across and I have been in diplomatic circles in business circles, and these are the best people. And
any one of you who has not been to a polyglot conference or who hasn't dipped your toe into language learning, I
suggest you get going. You will never regret it. And each language every language has its own reasons for being worthwhile
learning. And I'm going to try with my you know I have been away from some of these languages for a while
I'm gonna try to
comment
to each of the participants in the language that they used. And I will even just do it commit to providing
subtitles, which because I'm sometimes lazy,
I don't always do when I make videos in other languages. All right,
it starts with Benny and of course he begins by speaking English
so I'm speaking English, and I've already mentioned Benny, but I'll get back to Benny in different languages.
Then we had Lindsay. Lindsay is an enthusiastic person,
a person who can inspire others to learn languages. Thank you very much, Lindsay.
That was Lindsay. Then if I remember correctly,
Benny came back in sign language. I can't do sign language. I can just do "hi Benny".
That's about all I can do in sign language
I'm not sure I'll ever learn sign language, but I respect you for having learned it. Then I think we had
Kris speaking Danish. I am not going to speak Danish, I understand Danish. Swedish is enough but thank you.
or however they say in Danish and
Kris is a great guy and
very warm person and
I thank him for
apparently inspiring this video by discovering the fact that I had some kind of an old chair that I bought in a in a,
I guess it was a garage sale or something. I can't even remember
or a secondhand store.
Then we had Olly
I am in Swedish. You speak Cantonese very accurately, much better than me. When I speak Cantonese, my wife tells me off and say I am full of mistakes.
That's Olly speaking his wonderful Cantonese.
You speak very well. Thank you.
Thank him very much for his kind words.
Then we had Benny.
I can’t speak Portuguese like Benny. Benny speaks with a Brazilian accent that I can’t imitate. But I can only say that am envious , not sure if I can say that, of the way Benny speaks Portuguese.
Then we had Connor.
Thank you for what you said about my clothes. We were together in Lviv and it was very interesting to be with in Lviv.
Jan speaking Dutch. I'm not even gonna attempt Dutch. Jan is a great guy.
I met him on several of these occasions. Look forward hopefully you see him in Montreal.
I'm not gonna attempt Dutch, but I may learn Dutch one day ah
Mike. Not clear what you are saying . Do you mean that  while there is a debate between speaking from day one and the input method,  that there is a third way, the learning of whole sentences?
Mike Not clear what you are saying . Do you mean that  while there is a debate between speaking from day one and the input method,  that there is a third way, the learning of whole sentences?
I don’t fully agree. I believe that the basic element in a language is the phrase. That is why I focus on learning phrases. But everyone has a favourite study method and that is not a problem.Thank you for your explanation.
That was in Mandarin for
Mike Campbell. Then we had
Benny. I would like to travel in Italy with Benny and eat spaghetti , and talk about all these things, like the learning of languages (etc. in Ukrainian) as they say in Ukrainian.
What else do we have a Lydia and Petro. You know I had a great time in Slovakia
I had a wonderful time in Bratislava. There are many friendly people there.
Thank you for everything you did for the Bratislava
Polyglot Gathering. And then we had we have also Kersten.
Kerstin who spoke in German to present Jana and Judith. We hear Jana who spoke in Japanese and Judith in Esperanto. I didn’t understand anything.
Kerstin who spoke in German to present Jana and Judith. We hear Jana who spoke in Japanese and Judith who in Esperanto. I didn’t understand anything.
But I speak Japanese
and therefore if anything I understood what Jana had to say, of course I agree with her since I am in favour of focusing on input, so I was able to make sense of  what she had to say, since I understand Japanese, but...
Unfortunately, I don't speak Esperanto, however I...
Let us say I do recognize that Esperanto is a wonderful language
to learn as a means of encouraging students to
learn languages because it's easier to learn apparently, and therefore once people achieve success in learning one language, Esperanto, that may very well
encourage them to learn other languages. So,
there you have it, my response. But beyond anything else I want to thank the people who put this together. I
very much appreciate it, and I look forward to seeing most of you in Montreal
August 25th to 27th. Thank you very much. I hope I didn't forget anyone or didn't forget any language. Bye for now
I forgot to speak French.
So here I am again in my golf clothes. I wasn’t going to put my jacket back on.
A few days ago was the 14th of July and that reminded me to what extent I am thankful to France.
First of all I was in France as a foreign student but I had a French government scholarship so it was the French taxpayers who paid for my stay in France.
French is the first language I learned to speak fluently, that is the second language which gave me the confidence to speak other languages. I know that I can learn.
Not only that, but, as is the case for all the languages we learn, I learned so much about French culture and civilization.
This is a richness that I acquired via the language, which gives me the feeling of being, I don’t know, how would I put it, to have a greater breadth in my life, in the things that I can think about, the way I can express myself, the people with whom I can speak, and even more than that.
This is an experience that I have repeated many times with other languages, but it began with French and therefore I want especially to
I’m sorry I forgot to speak French in the video, and I thank not only Benny and his friends, but I thank France for this possibility that was given to me more than 50 years ago. Thank you and good-bye.
Thank you and good-bye.